with winston in 2015 a quarterback
presumed to be the first overall pick in
2015 it was winston then it was marcus
mariota
it could go three four it will go three
could go four maybe go five deep in the
first six or seven picks
that's good news for stephen jones and
the dallas cowboys as the quarterbacks
fly off the board he appeared yesterday
on 105.3 the fan in dallas
here's steven jones talking about the
cowboys draft strategy
this year given where they are you know
our standing policy here we don't want
you to have to
horn your answer in or anything but if
you're certain
about who y'all are gonna take we will
give you the
good very good we will give you a clean
slater
to go ahead and tell us what is going to
happen in the draft
you know pretty much unanimous people
are thinking there's five first-round
quarterbacks that certainly helps us out
since uh
we signed our quarterback of the future
just this
spring and know he's our answer to that
riddle but uh
we are we think going to get some great
opportunities because of the death not
only a quarterback but
offense in general and you know we
certainly want to improve our defensive
football team so certainly the top end
of that draft
helps us in terms of what we might see
there defensively
certainly this should be pushing some
defensive football players our direction
absolutely will push defensive players
their direction they may have a dilemma
top defensive player on the board versus
kyle pitts
or versus a tackle or yeah
but but it could play out the nine
selections
in front of the cowboys all are
offensive that's a way it could happen
and the cowboys would have their pick of
all the defensive players in the draft
edge russian middle linebacker corner
any area they want to address they're
going to address it they may have the
ability to trade down as well
chris we talked about that dynamic last
hour the cowboys are a team where the
power structure is going to be there
next year
maybe they see an opportunity to move
back a little bit pick up some more
lottery tickets maybe some for next year
where they have a better chance to scout
but either way when you have multiple
needs always better to consider sliding
back if you can yeah
no doubt about it i mean really it's
it's going to be interesting they are
sitting in a pretty spot i mean as far
as like a defensive
defensive needs you know i could sit
there and say maybe denver
might be a team that looks for defense
right maybe a little bit i think that
you could put them in that conversation
but not the same positions i don't think
dallas is looking for
dallas has got you know two things i
think you look at
yeah they i i think they could use a
legit you know edge pass rusher
opposite of lawrence i think that's like
a real thing to at least to me
or some difference making defense
alignment i don't think any d
tackle is worth 10 there so maybe if
they wanted to go that route they trade
down there
you know but but corner pass rusher
certainly and like you know i heard the
radio host there making the patrick
certain
jokes and all that that's i
you know i don't know if you made me say
who the cowboys are going to pick at
number 10 right now it would be that guy
you know they don't have corners i think
certain really
fits the kind of seattle atlanta
you know dan quinn's scheme right you
know he's a bigger guy
i don't think he's like the best
man-to-man corner but i think he's
really smart and can do
everything real good so he would fit
everything that way
that makes sense so if they stay at 10
i'm expecting to be patrick certain if
they drop
down i think they're probably looking
for
some sort of defensive lineman that they
feel like they could get just a little
bit later in the draft and get some
picks like you're talking about
patrick certain over your guy caleb
farley how dare you well
caleb farley to me no doubt
is the guy but that's mike that's the
amazing thing
i mean i don't know where he goes opt
out back surgeries
all of that he's a freak show you know
maybe that's why they trade down maybe
they realize like hey wait we could get
caleb barley maybe at 18
20 something like that you know maybe
that's why they do maybe they don't feel
comfortable about taking them at 10
but they'd feel better at 20. that's a
that's a possibility
you know the other thing i look at too
you know with like
jalen phillips the same thing jaylen
phillips or my money and i you know i
heard
um you know uh brandt uh gill brandt
right the other day i was i was
reading an article on him and he he
he made a comment about you know the
best pure pass rusher
the guy that could be a star out of the
defense is jaylen phillips i mean gil
brandt's around the cowboys a lot you
know i would think he'd be their type of
guy too
but you know again the concussion
history
all of that stuff missed football two
years ago by sitting out and
and all that maybe that's why they trade
down too maybe they got their eye on him
they don't feel comfortable at 10 and
they can go wait we can get him maybe at
18 or 20 or something like that so
interesting spot for the cowboys and a
lot of intrigue with this draft holy cow
you mentioned gilbran i got so much
respect for go brandon 89
still going straight crazy
and and you know the rest of us can only
hope that
that at that age number one we're still
around number two we're able to do
anything and number three we're able to
do the thing that we love and we still
have a love for it
yeah after that many years to still have
the passion it really is a remarkable
story and good that he finally got in
the hall of fame as he deserved to be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports